[MUSIC PLAYING]
JOE CORKERY: Thank
you, everybody.
I'm really excited to see
such a full room here today
to hear us talking about
keeping patient healthcare
data secure on Google
Cloud Platform.
I'm Joe Corkery.
I'm a product manager on the
Cloud Platform team, where
I'm leading our efforts in the
healthcare and life sciences
space in the product world.
I'm very excited about
this particular topic.
It's near and dear to me.
I'm actually a
non-practicing physician,
and found my way to
Google, and really
excited to talk
to you about this.
Here's a bit of an
overview of what I'm going
to be talking about today.
I'm going to start off by
talking about HIPAA compliance
on GCP--
what that means.
And then I'm going to
transition into best practices
for securing healthcare
data on the cloud--
how you should configure
your cloud environment
to take advantage of
the best practices.
At that point I'm going
to transition and invite
my co-presenter
Michael Ames on stage,
and he's going to talk
about the work they've done
at the University of Colorado--
how they were able to build the
health care EDW on the cloud
and hopefully give a brief
demo of that, as well.
And then, finally, because I
know Google Cloud encompasses
more than just Google
Cloud Platform,
I'm going to touch very briefly
on G Suite and health care,
as well.
Let's get started.
I don't know if all
of you have seen this,
but we published this
the week before HIMSS.
A new guide for HIPAA
compliance on GCP
to help people understand
what that means
as well as to understand best
practices for configuration.
So if you miss anything today,
you can either watch us again
on YouTube, or you can
go read that document.
Because most of what
I'm going to talk about
is also captured in there.
So by virtue of this being
a talk about health care,
I'm going to assume most
people here know what HIPAA is.
But in case you're
not aware of it,
it's US legislation that
provides data privacy
and security provisions
for the handling
of medical information.
Importantly, there
is no certification
recognized by the Department
of Health and Human Services
for HIPAA compliance.
And what that means
is I can't go out
and you can't go out
to some third party
and get a nice certificate that
says, this is HIPAA compliant,
and bring that
around to everybody.
So your HIPAA compliance is
really a shared responsibility
on your part-- well, it's a
responsibility on your part,
and when you're working
with the cloud provider,
it's a shared responsibility
between you and the cloud
provider.
What that means is customers
are responsible for securing
their data and the content
that they bring to the cloud,
and Google is
responsible for securing
the infrastructure on which
that data is stored, analyzed,
and consumed.
This is a high-level diagram
of the spectrum of the shared
responsibility model
across SaaS, PaaS,
Infrastructure as a Service.
And as you go from
the SaaS environment
all the way down to
the IaaS environment,
the ratio of
responsibility changes.
So when you look at a SaaS
model, like Gmail or Drive,
ultimately the customer is
responsible for the data
and who has access to
the data, but Google
has much greater responsibility
on securing everything
underneath it.
But as you move
to the IaaS model,
Google has the
responsibility for securing
the infrastructure, but
you, as the consumer,
are responsible
for the operating
system that you
install on top of it,
how you configure your
firewalls, and beyond.
I'm going to talk about these
terms a fair bit in the talk,
so I'm just going to
quickly define them
in case anybody is not
familiar with them.
Protected health
information is really
health information that
includes demographic info,
as well as information
that refers
to past, present, and
future medical information,
as well as the provision
of that health care,
and finally, also
the billing of that.
A covered entity is one
of, really, three things.
It's either a health plan, so an
insurance provider, or a health
care provider-- so a doctor,
physician, nurse, or hospital
system, or a health
care clearinghouse.
And finally, a
business associate
is an institution or a person
who works with a covered
entity, does work
on their behalf,
and as part of that work,
protected health information
is disclosed.
And in order for a covered
entity and a business associate
to work together, they
have to execute a Business
Associate Agreement that governs
how that transfer of data
is going to be managed
and controlled.
So this is an important point
I want to kind of sell home,
because I feel like not
everybody is well aware
of this.
But Google will enter into a
Business Associate Agreement
with customers as
necessary under HIPAA.
So in this context, if
you're a hospital system,
you're the covered entity,
Google's the business
associate, and we will
sign that agreement
so that you can bring
protected health
information to the cloud.
And we're able to sign this
because of our approach
to security and privacy design.
The cloud platform was
built under the guidance
of an engineering team of
more than 700 security--
over a 700 person
security engineering team.
Which is larger, and most
likely significantly larger,
than what most people
can have on premise.
And furthermore, our approach
to security, privacy, data
protection is well
documented in a number
of white papers,
design overviews
that you can go to this website,
our security page, and view.
In fact, earlier in
January we published
a well-documented
security design.
I would highly encourage
you to go review this--
it's really quite detailed--
and then share it with
anybody in your organization
who you think really needs
to understand the security
practices that Google
brings to bear in the cloud.
We're really excited about this.
It got well over 50,000 views
in the first couple of days.
It's worth looking.
It's worth sharing with anybody
who has an interest in that.
But it's all well and
good that we actually
perform these security practices
and that we document them,
but you as customers also want
to verify that, to validate it.
And so as part of
that, we participate
in a number of external
third-party audits
on an annual basis to get SOC
2 compliance, ISO 27001, 27017,
so on.
So that way you can
know that somebody else
has gone in and verified the
designs and the practices
that we say.
As I mentioned before,
there is no certifying party
for HIPAA compliance,
so I can't put that
on that list over there.
But it's because of
these compliance audits
that we go through, as well as
our own security and privacy
designs, that we feel
comfortable being
able to offer a Business
Associates Agreement.
The Business
Associates Agreement
covers a number of things.
In particular, it covers the
infrastructure-- all regions,
zones, network paths,
points of presence--
for these related services
that are listed here.
There are 10 services right now.
It's grown significantly
over the past year or two
and will continue
to grow over time.
And when you sign the
Business Associate Agreement,
it covers your utilization
of these products.
There are a couple of really
unique, interesting features,
though, as a result of
our security practices
feeding into our BAA.
And because the BAA covers
the infrastructure underlying
these products and not just a
secured set of infrastructure
to run just that in a
HIPAA compliant fashion,
it means you don't have
any regional restrictions.
So you get security,
operational,
and scalability benefits
of having access
to the entire infrastructure.
It means you can have
multi-regional redundancy.
So if, for instance,
you're storing
a lot of healthcare
data in the cloud,
you don't have to be
limited to one data center.
So you can store the data
in GCS on the East Coast
and on the West
Coast, and if you
have temporary unavailability,
you can fail over from one
to the other relatively easily.
Furthermore, as
part of this, you
can use any of the
VM instance types.
So you can take advantage
of preemptible VMs, which
are very useful in terms
of saving a lot of money
for batch workloads,
where you're
tolerant to the VM
coming down and being
able to easily restart it.
With all that in
mind, and because we
don't have to actually build
out and maintain a completely
separate infrastructure
stack in order
to offer you a HIPAA
compliant environment,
we can offer the same pricing.
There are no additional
fees, charges, taxes,
commitments that you
have to make in order
to operate under the BAA.
Let me talk a little
bit now about some
of the specific customer
responsibilities.
I have two questions
that you really need
to answer before we move on.
And the first one is, you
need to answer for yourself--
are you a covered
entity, or a business
associate of a covered entity?
And then you also
need to answer,
does the workload that
you want to bring to cloud
require that you have a Business
Associate Agreement with GCP?
I can't answer these
questions for you.
Hopefully you already
know these answers.
And if you don't,
I would encourage
you to seek legal advice.
Now, if you answered yes
to both of those questions,
this is what needs
to happen first--
first thing you
need to do is you
need to execute a
cloud platform BAA.
And that's done in the context
of a larger services agreement.
And then for that environment
that you're working in,
you need to ensure that you
can disable or otherwise ensure
that you're not using
Google Cloud products that
are not explicitly
covered by the BAA
when you're handling PHI.
And finally-- and this goes back
to that shared responsibility
model--
you need to ensure that
anything that you build
on top of this
infrastructure also meets
the HIPAA requirements.
So any applications
that you might install,
as well as your use
of that application.
So let's talk a little bit
more about individual best
practices.
I'm going to start off with
identity and access management.
The first real
principle to be aware of
is this principle
of least privilege.
And this is the idea
that nobody should
be granted permissions
beyond what they absolutely
need to get their job done.
So you should not be granting
permissions to everybody
in your organization
to the data.
You should not be
giving everybody
owner roles on the projects.
Instead what you
should do is you
should put the work together in
as small projects as possible,
grant specific roles to
those individual projects,
and only give people
who have a business
need for that those
particular roles.
As part of that, we encourage
people to use groups.
And what you can do is you
can take groups and assign
a permission to go to
that group as opposed
to assigning a permission
to an individual user.
And what that means
is you can say,
OK, this is our
security admin group.
And people in security admin
group have these permissions.
And if I remove you
from that group,
you lose all those permissions.
You don't have to go and
change your whole IAM policy
for your project to remove you.
It makes it very
easy, especially
with people moving around.
But part of that
means you also need
to tightly control who has the
ability to change identities
and policies.
So you want tight
configuration over who
has user management, group
management, and IAM policies.
In addition to that, you also
want to audit policy changes
with some frequency.
In particular, you want
to go and look and say,
were the changes that
were made appropriate?
What you can see
on the screen right
now is a screenshot
of the activity panel
on the cloud console, which
is showing you an IAM policy
change.
And I'll talk a little
bit more about auditing
a little further on.
And then this last
bit with regard to IAM
is we encourage people to rotate
your service account keys.
Or if you're not going to
actually do the rotation,
to have a plan in
place for how you're
going to rotate those keys
if you need to do that.
And this is important
because the service account
key is what allows you to
authenticate as that service
account.
So if that key
gets lost, you want
to be able to rotate
it very quickly,
so that nobody has access
to that service account.
Encryption-- this is kind
of an easy story for us
here, because all
customer content
is encrypted at rest on
Google Cloud Platform.
We're the only cloud platform
to provide that by default.
What I need you to
ask yourself then
is does your organization
have any other encryption
requirements beyond what
is required by HIPAA?
And if you do, we
have options for you.
And they run along a spectrum
from highly automated--
of the everything is
encrypted by default--
to the more managed key
management service, as well as
the ability to provide your own
customer-supplied encryption
keys.
I'm going to talk
briefly about storage.
So if you're using
cloud storage,
we encourage people to
use GCS Object Versioning,
because this is very useful
for building a Data Archive,
as well as protecting
against accidental data
deletion-- which I know is often
an important requirement when
handling healthcare data.
There is a tool that people
use with cloud storage called
gsutil.
And there are a couple security
and privacy configuration
things that you should
be aware of there.
First of all, you never
want to share credentials.
Everybody should bring their
own credential when they use it.
And that's important
because sometimes secure
sensitive information can be
captured in the configuration
file for that application.
And so you want to
tightly protect access
to that for whoever is using it.
And more importantly,
if you're going
to use this in a
production environment,
use a service account credential
instead of individual user
credentials.
It's easier to control.
Audit logs-- these are what
allow you to know who did what,
where, when on your platform.
Very valuable, especially
when you're working
with health information.
There are two types
of audit logs.
There's the Admin Activity
Log, which basically captures
all the actions that you
take that make a change
to a resource or your service.
And then there's
the Data Access Log,
which captures all
the requests to read,
as well as all the interactions
with the data managed
by that service.
So if you were having
a database service
and actually touching
the data, that's
where those logs
would be captured.
I have a couple of examples
of typical operations as they
would be classified,
one or the other.
You can see up here
right now there
are two ways that the audit
logs get surfaced to the users.
On one hand you'll see the
cloud activity console,
which provides you a high-level
overview-- basically tells
you what are the important
points and makes it really easy
for you to see.
On the right is
the raw log being
able to be seen inside
of StackDriver logging
logs viewer.
So if you want the full
details to actually look
at the individual logs, you
can see them right there.
Let's talk a little
bit about some
of the best practices for
audit logs when you're
working in this environment.
What we encourage people to
do is we encourage people to,
first, set up their
export destinations.
So you want to send your logs to
another location for long term
archival.
You can send them to GCS
for long term archival.
You can also send
them to BigQuery
and use that for
archival, as well as
forensics and analytics.
I'm seeing a lot of
interest in using BigQuery
as a tool for log analysis.
We also want you
to configure access
to the logs in a way
that's appropriate
to your organization.
So as I said earlier on the
topic of least privilege,
you only want to
give people who need
to see the logs the
right to see the logs.
And actually there
are three permissions
that you should be aware of.
There's the logs
viewer permission.
And the logs viewer
permission grants you access
to the admin activity logs.
There's the private
logs viewer permission,
which grants you access
to the data access logs.
And we decided to give
them an extra permission,
because we thought
perhaps that data
might be a little
bit more sensitive,
and you might want to
break out who could
look at one versus the other.
And then the final permission
that you should be aware of
is the logs config
writer permission.
And a person with the logs
config writer permission
is a person who can set up
new export destinations.
And this is a pretty
powerful permission,
because it allows you to
take your logs out of here
and send them somewhere else.
So you should not--
the person with that
permission should be very few.
And finally, as I
talked about earlier,
you want to regularly
review these audit logs.
And you can do them inside
of StackDriver logs viewer.
You can do it inside of
BigQuery or with a variety
of third party tools.
So we support
exporting your logs
to other external destinations.
So you can take
advantage of Splunk,
Netskope, Rapid7 log entries,
as well as Tenable Network
Security, to use those
for log analysis.
And this is my last
topic on best practices
before I hand it off to Michael.
And this is what I like
to think is ideally
a commonsense thought--
but please don't include
PHI or security credentials
in your resource metadata.
Resource metadata often
gets captured in the logs,
and that's really
not a good practice.
So as I said-- and actually
I want to emphasize this--
the audit logs themselves
never contain the data
contents of a resource.
But by virtue of capturing
the actions that happened,
they often may
capture the metadata
associated with that resource.
So in best practices,
don't name your buckets
after your patients.
Don't name your objects
Use other identifiers.
So with that I want to step down
for a second and transition.
Michael, please come on up.
Thank you.
MICHAEL AMES: All right.
Health care people are the most
dedicated people in the world.
It is 4:30 PM.
It's been a long day.
This room is almost full.
Thank you for being here.
I hope that by the end
it will be worth it.
Now, I can't see
you really well,
but if you'll do this
for me-- raise your hand
if right now your
organization has
protected health information
on the Google Cloud today.
OK.
Now put your hand down
if you work for me.
OK.
Now raise your hand
if you would do it
if you could, if you could
get over the organizational
and the security hurdles,
if you could talk
your people into
saying, yeah, we
can do this-- put your hands up.
Great.
OK.
This presentation is for you.
And this is a great time to be a
healthcare-related organization
looking at a move to the cloud.
And I'll tell you, part
of why it's a great time
is a year ago--
I was here with my team,
and my team is here.
Thank you.
I was here with my team and
talking to everybody I could
find-- from Google,
other customers,
and the leadership circle--
saying, hey, we're trying to
get our PHI up onto the cloud,
and we want to do it right.
Where is the HIPAA
security playbook
that's going to tell us how
to do this in a way that
is safe and secure, and is going
to protect patient privacy,
and keep us all out of jail?
And everybody was like, you
know, that's a good idea.
We should get one of those.
Right?
But it wasn't there.
And we spent a lot of time on
our own, working with our team,
working with external
partners, with Google,
trying to figure out
the right way to do it.
And what Joe has just presented
is that playbook that we wished
had been here a
year ago that isn't.
And you have that now.
So this is a great time to
be embarking on that journey.
And what I'm going
to talk to you about
is what our journey
looked like, and then
go back and talk specifically
about some things
that you might take back to try
to win this battle for hearts
and minds within
your organization,
to allow you to take this
step-- move to the cloud,
enjoy the technical
benefits that we've
been learning about here, and do
it in a safe and secure manner.
So part one-- what we did.
This is a little bit about us.
My organization is on the bottom
of that right square there--
Health Data Compass.
We're an enterprise
health data warehouse
within a larger organization,
the Colorado Center
for Personalized Medicine.
This is a great organization
that was formed just recently,
collaborative between UC Health,
Children's Hospital Colorado,
CU Medicine, and the University
of Colorado School of Medicine,
who got together and
said, what could we
do better than we're doing
today if we put all of our data
in one place?
And specifically,
what can we do to help
to advance this field of
personalized medicine?
For those of you for whom that's
a new term, or a vague buzz
word, for us what it means
is let's gather as much data
as we can about every patient
at the clinical level.
Let's then go in and
gather everything
we can learn about them from a
molecular, genetic standpoint.
Let's put that together
and analyze that data
and see if we can figure
out how to deliver
targeted diagnoses
and targeted therapies
based on everything we can
possibly learn about you--
not just the
handful of questions
that the doctor is asking when
you show up at the bedside.
So that's our job.
And specifically within
Health Data Compass,
we are tasked with
that integration
of these vast amounts
of data in a way
that our researchers and
hospital administrators
can use it to serve a
wide variety of purposes.
I'm going to give you a little
bit of company history now.
This is our affectionately-named
"Compass Hope-O-Meter."
Because we are data
people, we like
to put numbers to our emotions.
And you can see here, we kicked
off in the summer of 2013
with a pile of money
and a huge mission.
And as we began to
work on this project,
going through the stages of
figuring out our requirements,
developing an RFP, putting
that RFP out there.
I remember the day--
I still have the photo--
that we were able to finally
look at these 20 thick binders,
with proposals from different
vendors who were going to come
help us solve our data
integration project.
We were so excited.
And we launched.
We chose our vendor.
We started to launch our
building efforts in the summer
of 2014 with high hopes.
And then what happens?
Right.
Many of you have been
through this cycle
where once you get your
hands on the technology
and you start to work
with it, you realize--
this is harder than we
thought it was going to be.
That sales pitch
sounded so good, right?
And now, as we're working
with it more and more,
we're finding ourselves a
little bit more disappointed.
But we did, by the
skin of our teeth,
reach our go-live in
the spring of 2015.
Now, notice how much time
passed between our go-live
and our Hope-O-Meter
dropping to all-time lows.
About three months
was all it took.
We were having some trouble.
We were drowning
under the weight
of maintaining what turned
out to be a very heavy, very
brittle, very error-prone
on-premises infrastructure.
It was a top-to-bottom
stack, all of one
brand, supposedly tightly
integrated, and was going
to service all of our needs.
And it was possible to
achieve that but only
at tremendous effort
and expense that, to us,
felt like constantly
having to go back and flip
on a really heavy, really
costly light switch.
All it did was keep
the system running.
And we were spending
resources on those activities
that we would much rather have
spent on value-added activities
for our stakeholders.
We expected the server to
blaze right out of the box.
We had a lot of
off-the-shelf software
we expected was
just going to work.
And what we had hoped was
that by investing so heavily--
in what, honestly,
was the most expensive
of that big stack of
binders and proposals--
that we would be
able to accelerate
to business objectives.
The reality is that
wasn't the case.
And that presented us
with a problem and was,
frankly, quite depressing.
And then we had an
interesting day.
So this is my good friend Mary
Anne Leach, whom some of you
may know.
She is a great--
International Women's
Week-- another
of these great
visionary women leaders
in health care, whom
we're celebrating.
She was CIO of Children's
Hospital at the time.
And she had this idea,
she called me up,
and she said, hey, I just
got invited to a thing
to go learn about
the Google Cloud.
Do you want to come?
At which point I
rolled my eyes, right?
Because she's a visionary,
she's a thinker.
And the thing about visionary
people with great ideas is they
have a lot of ideas--
they're not always good, right?
And she was one of these.
And I thought,
[GROAN] I don't know.
Until she said it's
at a fancy steakhouse.
Google legal made me redact
the name of that steakhouse,
all right, but we went
to a fancy steakhouse.
And I thought, OK, I
could be persuaded.
And so we got together and we
went to this Google Cloud Sales
pitch downtown,
wherein we discovered
that there was no steak.
No steak at all.
There were only canapes.
Do I look like a guy
who was happy to be
served a piece of
fish on a cracker
when I thought there was steak?
No, I am not that guy.
But what we did do is we
spent the day learning
about the Google Cloud
from Doug Daniels, who's
here in the second row.
And he was talking
about BigQuery.
about Google Genomics.
And he was talking
about this concept
of operating on a completely
serverless architecture.
And think about where we were,
drowning under the weight
of maintaining our servers--
our minds were blown.
Do you like my
classy diagrams here?
So we started to think,
well, this would be amazing.
And where was this two
years ago when we started?
How come we didn't
know about this then?
And we realized,
as we considered
this question about
could we shift
our operations to the
cloud, that there were
some things that had changed.
In those couple of years,
there were significant advances
in cloud technology.
There are new attitudes
about cloud services.
When I started at the
University back in 2009,
you talked about putting
data in the cloud,
they would laugh
you out of the room.
And people were
starting to think
about this as maybe a reality.
We understood better the
potential of the business case,
and we had learned some
things, and we thought maybe
we could do this.
But I want to tell you a
little bit about the challenge
that we had to overcome.
Like I showed in
that first slide,
there are four separate
legal institutions
involved in our organization--
two major hospital
systems in Colorado, a
university, and a physician
practice plan.
Which, even though many
of them have their roots
in the university,
are literally now
separate legal institutions.
One does not operate the other.
Each of them has their
own security officer,
privacy officer, legal officer.
We have a steering committee
consisting of executives
from all of those organizations.
And put yourself in my shoes--
going in front of
this group of people
and asking for a do-over just
a few months after our go-live.
But we felt like-- given the
experiences that we were having
and our responsibility to our
stakeholders and our patients--
that we needed to take
care of every opportunity
that we could.
So here is how we
strategized this.
We said, lets do with
Google what we could not
do with our original system.
It took less than
six months for us
to realize that we were
having serious problems.
And we set out to do a
detailed pilot project
on the Google Cloud platform--
in six months, in stealth
mode, not telling anybody
who didn't need to know--
while we continued to build out
and operate our legacy system.
Now, how is this possible?
We're going to talk in a little
bit about zero-depth entry,
and pay-as-you-go models,
and how it enables this kind
of thing, where
traditional models do not.
And we laid out this plan,
and we executed this plan.
And we did it with the intent
to answer these questions.
We wanted to find out, is
it compliant, legal, safe?
Can we do everything
we need to know?
We literally built all of the
components necessary to operate
our data warehouse.
Because we did not--
I can ask for one do over.
I can ask for two--
at which point I
sharpen up my resume
and I go find other jobs, right?
We only had one chance
to do this a second time.
So we had to make sure that
we were getting it right.
We wanted to make sure that
the capabilities were there,
and also measure costs
and long-term benefits,
so that we could make a
compelling case for why
our organization should
make this change.
Which we did, and we
built this in six months.
So you can see here
our data sources
coming in from our
hospital partners
and from the Colorado
Department of Public Health.
Because one of the things
that we wanted to prove
was the effectiveness of this
platform in integrating data
that came from sources
other than our own.
We load that data into
the Google Cloud platform,
through Google Cloud
Storage, Google Genomics,
into Google BigQuery.
We transform, we
clean, we harmonize,
we do all of the work
there in the cloud.
So, again, follow
me-- for those of you
who work in data
flow architectures,
we load the data as unchanged
as possible into the cloud,
and we let the
scalability of BigQuery
be our friend in doing all
of the transformations that
are necessary.
And then we deliver
reports via Tableau.
We have since
continued to build,
and we continue to have a vision
of building out additional data
sources.
There's probably a list
of 20 other data sources
down there that we're
working to integrate.
In addition to these
applications that we're
exporting data to, my
outstanding analyst and BI team
spends a lot of time delivering
one-off data extracts
to researchers.
These people who stay
up late at night,
and they come to
us in the morning,
and they've got an idea
for a research project.
And they just want to
know, do we have the data?
Do we have the patient
population to support this?
Very specific, ad-hoc questions.
And they ask us those, and
we provide those to them
based on this platform.
So we built this thing, and
we measured the results,
and here are some
things that we found.
On the left side is an ETL
performance comparison.
Now, it's tough to do
apples-to-apples ETL comparison
when you're dealing with
on-premises systems versus
systems that are
sort of hybrid--
moving from an on-premise
system up into the cloud.
But we figured the
most honest way
to do this is to look
at end-to-end ETL.
So we start with
extracting data on one end.
We end with when it has reached
its final destination up
in the cloud.
And as you can see there, we
achieved a 50% performance
improvement, even
including the time
that it took to upload that
data through the internet
from our campus
up onto the cloud.
And here is an outlier,
but just to show you
some of the things
that are possible.
And in fact, I'm to
come back to this.
But any of you operate
a master patient index?
Know what I'm talking about?
A few of you.
We had a big win
there, but we'll
talk about that a little
bit more in a minute.
When I show these costs
I'm always asked--
and Google legal asked--
are there real
numbers behind this?
There are.
These are our annual
infrastructure costs.
I'm not giving you
the real numbers,
but the ratio there is correct.
You can see that having
moved from our legacy system
to Google BigQuery,
we anticipate
spending 60% less on
annual infrastructure cost.
And we've operated this
now for close to 10 months,
and we have actual data to
validate those numbers for us.
Projecting that out
over five years,
you can see that year
over year we experience
reductions in cost and a
cumulative total infrastructure
reduction, again, of around 60%.
And if I was being
totally honest,
that reduction would
even be higher.
Because you can see in fiscal
year '20-- that big red bar
represents end-of-life equipment
for our on-premises system
and the need to replace that.
If we were really
doing it right,
we actually would have done
an expansion of our system
in fiscal year
'17, and that would
drive that ratio even higher.
So we did this pilot, we
got these great results.
I want to back up
now a little bit
and talk about how you take
on the battle for hearts
and minds.
So we have this committee.
I told you about these
four institutions.
And each of them has a
security officer, each of them
has a privacy officer, each
of them has an attorney.
And once a month, they literally
get around a boardroom table
that looks just like that for us
to bring our questions to them.
Now, Google legal--
I normally present
this slide with a bunch
of cropped-out pictures
of Nancy Reagan's face.
Think about it.
With all respect to our lovely
and elegant former First Lady,
we call this the Nancy
Reagan committee.
Because the security
officer, the privacy officer,
the legal person, all have
just one job description,
which is--?
AUDIENCE: Just say no.
MICHAEL AMES: Just say no.
Right?
And we had to persuade
this group of people
that it was safe for all four
of their institutions to have
their data moved to the Cloud.
Here's how you go about this.
Recognize that the risk
that they're looking at
is three-fold.
They're concerned
about the cost,
because the cloud is unknown.
They're very concerned
about security,
because that's paramount.
And in general, the
cloud is unfamiliar.
And these are the problems
that you have to tackle.
There is, in the
end, only one thing
that will make a difference.
And that is the
business case that
proves that the
rewards are going
to be greater than the risks.
And you're going to answer cost
by demonstrating that there's
going to be increased
revenue, or cost savings,
by moving to the cloud.
You're going to answer
security by saying,
the security is going to be
better when we get there.
We will fulfill our
responsibility to our patients
more fully by taking
advantage of those 700
security and
compliance engineers
that Joe talked about.
And you're going
to answer concerns
about the unknown
with opportunities
to innovate that you'll
be able to take advantage
of in the cloud that you
won't in other places.
Here is part of a
helpful way, I hope,
of talking about
cost versus value.
Because in the end, the
money aspect of this matters.
So that blue area
represents investment
in infrastructure
capacity, which
has this stepwise function.
That red line is your
usage on that capacity.
And let's just assume that
it's going up kind of flat
over time.
You can twist and warp
this model all you want,
but it gives you the same
results, more or less.
As you approach
capacity, you need
to expand upon your
infrastructure.
And you make a big investment,
and you deploy out new servers,
and then you do that again
after some period later.
And the thing that happens
is the infrastructure
that you had invested
in that you're not
using-- that time between when
you first make the purchase
and when you start to reach
capacity is considered waste.
That's money that you've
spent that you aren't using.
And look how that
adds up over time.
That orange line shows how
that wasted area accumulates.
This has a dramatic effect
on total cost of ownership.
And the model, when you
move to an infrastructure
where you can scale up
more closely to your usage
changes this significantly.
So here's a
pay-as-you-go model--
only investing in the
infrastructure that you need.
With systems like BigQuery,
that stepwise function
is even flatter, because
you're literally only
paying for queries
as you execute them.
But even if you're
deploying virtual machines,
and you're able to gradually
scale those out and build them
up, we have the same usage.
We have the same slope.
But the mean is much lower.
And look what happens to
the accumulated waste--
it is much, much smaller.
This has a dramatic effect on
your total cost of ownership,
and in my opinion, is one
of the strongest arguments
for a move to the cloud from
an economic point of view.
I want to verify with our
folks that this clock is
counting down.
It's telling me how much time
we have left in the session?
Yes?
OK.
Great.
I was confused for a second.
Second thing-- it's time
to change the conversation.
So this was a release
from about last October
from HHS on HIPAA
and cloud computing.
The question of, oh, will
the government get mad at us
if we put data in
the cloud any more?
The answer to that is no.
This guidance exists.
You can go look it up online
on a government website.
You can read it.
It has very specific,
very helpful guidance
for how to engage effectively
with a cloud service provider.
And my recommendation
is that you
stop talking about this,
like, gee, I don't know
if we can do this in the cloud.
But the fact is
the advantages are
so strong that the
conversation needs to be--
how quickly can we get there?
A little repeat from some
of what Joe talked about--
recognize that in
terms of security
there is a joint responsibility.
Google owns physical
infrastructure, platform,
and Software as a
Service level security.
You still own everything
top to bottom,
and this is important,
again, in this battle
for hearts and minds.
Because you have your security
and compliance officers,
they need to have
confidence that you know
what you are talking about.
And the moment you
go in and say, oh,
we're going to
move this to Google
and they're going to
take care of security,
they will know that you don't
know what you're talking about.
You have a responsibility
to understand
what your responsibility is.
And you need to be able
to speak this language.
You need to understand
what it really
means to be HIPAA compliant.
You don't need to understand
how encryption algorithms work,
but you need to understand
where the responsibilities lie,
and the difference
between technical security
and organizational
level controls,
and to be able to define--
here's what we're going
to get from Google,
and here's what we're going
to have to do ourselves.
If you can't speak
that language,
find somebody who can,
and get them to help you,
get them on your
side, and have them
help you to advocate for
the security of the cloud.
Here's another way to do it.
This is Fort Knox.
Google legal made me go back
and get a non-copyrighted photo
of Fort Knox.
Google has built Fort
Knox in their data center.
It is literally true that the
South Carolina data center
has alligators on the property.
Not as a formal part of
the security mechanism,
but they sort of moved in.
And Google said, that's fine.
We'll leave them there.
And they put up some "beware
of alligators" signs,
and it's going to help.
How many of you have alligators
outside your data center?
Not many.
You still have this
responsibility.
You can build the strongest
vault in the world.
If you leave it unlocked, you're
going to have problems, right?
So those orange bars--
your responsibility.
Again, what Google
does, what we do.
Joe already talked about all
of the different compliance
and certifications of--
my HIPAA with the
asterisk here--
just to repeat
what he said, there
is no HIPAA certification.
If somebody tells you that
they have one, they're lying.
What they have is maybe a
third party auditor who said,
yeah, we think that
this is HIPAA compliant.
But the government
hasn't set a checkbox way
to say that you're
HIPAA compliant.
So there is some judgment
that you've got to take there.
It's going to feel
like you're never done.
That's fine-- sleep
is for mortals.
Recognize that Google is--
I'll be honest.
One of the things that brought
comfort to our legal folks
was recognizing that in
the event of a breach that
was Google's fault, Google's
got a lot of resources
that in the event
of a lawsuit, we're
confident they could
probably cover our expenses.
Right?
If that had to happen.
We hope that never happens.
But there is work here
for you to do as well.
Map those various
compliance certifications
to whatever requirements
your organization has.
If you want to throw independent
pen testers at it to make
people comfortable, do that.
In fact, one of the early things
that we sort of said, wow,
I think we're going down
the right path is-- again,
I asked Doug Daniels--
I said, if we wanted to
have our in-house white hat
hackers go after
this thing and try
to penetrate BigQuery,
or something like that,
could they do that?
Or would we get in trouble?
And he's like, go for it.
Because Google is doing
this always themselves.
They're giving out
money to people
who are trying to
hack their system.
You can build hybrid monitoring
and alerting systems.
If you have local
systems, or if you're
using Splunk, or
Nagios, or other systems
that your security people
are comfortable with--
fine.
Let them have those things.
And build mechanisms that allow
them to use hybrid approaches
to monitoring and alerting.
And watch the contracts.
I was going to
make a whole slide,
but there's probably
another hour
on making sure that
your contracts are
unambiguous and appropriate
liabilities are set up.
Finally, to the
innovation point.
Please think beyond
the lift and shift--
let's get our virtual machines
out of our data center
and onto Google.
There have been a
lot of discussions
here and in the keynotes about
how you do this incrementally.
Fine to take an
incremental approach,
but don't get your VMs
out of your data center
and into Google's and
consider yourself done.
Because the greatest gains are
to be had in the cloud 2.0,
cloud 3.0--
thinking beyond virtual
machines and into SaaS and PaaS
offerings.
So here's one.
Couple of super
smart guys on my team
here work together to see--
hey, every time
we do a data load
we have to take these six
million patient records
and do this big fuzzy
match cross-join.
We want to find out if Bobby
Peterson at the Children's
Hospital is the same as
Roberta Peterson at the adult
hospital with
10-year-apart visits.
That's a tricky problem.
It's a huge
computational challenge.
And any of you who
operate systems like this,
you know it's not
a small effort.
Our legacy system had
an expensive application
and server that this
ran on, and to do
that six-million-record
fuzzy cross-join
took about eight hours.
They reimplemented
this in BigQuery,
using BigQuery's user
defined functions,
using JavaScript in order
to do the fuzzy matching.
Ran it, and it finished
in about 15 minutes,
and it cost us about $1.50
every time we ran it,
in terms of BigQuery
computational power.
That is the kind
of win that you can
get when you look beyond just
moving your virtual machines
into the sky and
say, what can we
do with some of these
scalable, serverless tools that
are out there?
What could you do if suddenly
you didn't have to keep asking,
do we have enough storage space?
Do we have enough compute power?
What could you do
with zero-depth entry?
That six month pilot
started in about March.
In about June, my
wife came upstairs
and said, why do we have
a multi-thousand dollar
bill to Google on our
personal credit card?
Because back in March, I sat
on my couch, in my pajamas,
and signed up for
our Google account
on my personal credit
card and didn't notice it
for three months.
Because as we were starting
to load data in and work
with the system in
this stealth mode
project that costs
were negligible.
And it wasn't until
we started deploying
lots of data and lots
of virtual machines
that it even hit the radar
on the credit card bill.
Don't do that.
Google legal doesn't make
it easy to get that back.
But we did get it back.
Thank you again, Doug Daniels,
and apologies to my wife.
So we got that done.
But the point is,
the fact that you
can make that
mistake accidentally
certainly means that you
won't need CFO authorization
and a big CAPEX spend in
order to start playing around.
I think everybody here
has got a $300 credit.
I think they've extended
the period from six months
to 12 months for
the trial period.
Get in and start with this
zero-depth entry approach,
seeing what you can do.
Think about cloud-first
architectures.
So we're taking our
data, we're pushing it
into the cloud unchanged, and
we're doing all the work there.
What could you do if people
could get to your data
from all over the region
or all over the world?
What can you do with the
integration between your data
in the cloud and these amazing
cloud-based analytical tools
that are out there?
And given that you will
hopefully save money, what do
you do with that?
You take that money,
you don't give it back,
and you redirect that toward
value-added activities.
For us that means
hiring more analysts,
bringing in more
data sources, working
on improving our customer
relationship management
approaches, and building
a better organization that
is much more focused
on delivering value.
I'm not going to
repeat all this.
This is summarizing
what we just said.
You've got to build
the business case.
You've got to make sure that
you can speak to the security.
And you've got to
focus on innovation.
That's all I have by
way of information.
I wanted to give some thank
yous to the folks on the screen
here who really helped us in
building these things out,
figuring out our
security approaches,
helping us with processes,
architecture design.
Huge thanks to my team,
most of whom are here,
and who really were the
hands on doing this work.
And let me just ask
Joe-- do we have time?
Do we want to hit that demo?
We've got 12 minutes
left on here.
JOE CORKERY: Yeah.
MICHAEL AMES: OK.
So we just want to prove that
we're not making stuff up here.
Here's our Twitter handle
if you want to follow us.
We don't tweet a lot,
but there's stuff there.
Maybe we'll make friends.
Couple of screenshots
and then a running demo,
if it works, of actual things
that we have actually built.
Here is a dashboard in Tableau
that shows top 10 disease
diagnoses for one of
our hospital systems,
with lots of information about
the distribution across sex
and race, co-morbidities,
distribution over patient age.
And the fun thing is you
can click down on that list,
and you can see this refresh,
and the numbers change.
Scanning 133 million
diagnosis records,
and it refreshes and does
all that recalculating
in about 10 seconds.
Here's a static copy of the
thing I'm going to show you
that tells us a little bit
about how the flu is spreading
in the Denver metro area, year
over year, and time over time.
And I'm told that
for this to work,
I have to come click on this.
This works, right?
That moves.
Check it out.
This is in Tableau.
And you can see on
the left in that map,
those dots are our
various clinics,
and we're seeing the rate at
which the flu is spreading.
And we're comparing
that year over year
with each of those
columns on the right.
Again, kudos to my
team and to our great
BI developers and
analysts who figured out
how to put this thing together.
We're going to let that
flow for just a minute,
because at the end something
really cool happens.
One of the unexpected
side benefits
of moving to Google
BigQuery is being
able to take advantage
of Google's efforts
to bring public data
sets into BigQuery.
For those of you who haven't
worked with BigQuery,
the interesting
thing is it's sort
of like one great
big, shared DBMS.
You have data, other
people have data,
and assuming that the
permissions are set correctly,
you can join across
to different data sets
with literally one join
statement in your SQL command.
So you'll see this thing
come to the end of its period
here in just a minute.
Look at that big spike in 2014.
The scientists got the flu
vaccine wrong that year,
and we're a little
bit nervous about what
2016 is looking like.
But now, just to see
what's possible here,
the magical mouse is going
to move up, click a button.
We're going to color code
those trends on the top
according to weather.
So that is blue when it's
cold, and red when it's warm.
And that data was brought in
almost instantly with one join
to a public data set from Google
that talks about daily weather
station data.
So we build real
stuff with this.
And that's all I have.
So thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
JOE CORKERY: All
right, I'm going
to go through this last part
pretty quickly, because I
want to make sure we have time
for Phil to join us on stage.
So in addition to
Google Cloud Platform,
G Suite is a popular tool
in the healthcare business
to provide secure productivity
tools to help you help others.
I've always enjoyed this quote
here about G Suite from Roche--
and actually I think the
original quote says "apps"
because that's when they adopted
before it was called G Suite--
saying, "G Suite will allow
our employees to focus on what
matters most--
saving patient lives."
Much like I talked
about earlier--
HIPAA compliance guides.
We also have one for G Suite.
If you go to the
G Suite site, you
can get that information there
on how to properly configure
that environment to bring
PHI to the cloud for use
in these productivity tools.
And with that, I
wanted to invite Phil
back up to talk about
the work that Veritas
is doing to help customers with
their G Suite in healthcare.
Thank you, Phil.
PHIL YACCINO: Thank you.
Hi, everyone.
I'm Phil Yaccino with Veritas.
What Veritas is able
to provide for G Suite
is really a Software
as a Service product
that helps you move to the
cloud and helps you be compliant
with HIPAA regulations.
So what we do, essentially, is
provide a compliant repository
for your mail data.
So your Gmail information
that comes to you,
it gets brought into
our EV.Cloud product.
EV.Cloud makes what we refer
to as an immutable copy.
So it can't be deleted,
it can't be altered,
it can't be changed.
What we're then able to
do is provide a workflow
that allows you to do search
and production for legal matters
or compliance matters.
So if you have needs
to prove that there
is data that has user-based
information in it
or patient-based
information, you
can search for that
and output that
for the need that you have.
Additionally, you can
also do the same thing
for court matters.
So it gives a lot
of flexibility,
and it's all within
an audited process.
So you're able to
have chain of custody,
you have legal
discovery, and also be
able to respond for requests
for patient data as well.
So it gives you those--
covers those three areas and
allows your HIPAA compliance
at the same time.
And really, that's the goal.
It allows you to
simplify your workflows.
It allows you to meet
regulatory and legal compliance,
and able to improve your both
IT infrastructure and also
your eDiscovery
productivity, as well.
So basically what
we're able to do
is a "better
together" scenario, be
able to improve what G
Suite already has in place,
and give you a product that
allows you to be compliant
with regulatory needs.
[MUSIC PLAYING]